[Music]
Disney have just dropped a ton of new
information on their upcoming Netflix
rival streaming service named Disney
Plus there's a lot of things that unpack
from the announcement so I thought I'd
put together a video breaking down
everything you can expect to see from it
when it releases later this year there's
a wealth of information to unpack
so without the way I'm your host
definition and let's get into everything
you need to know about the new service
ok so first things first
Disney Plus is set to launch on November
12th in America at the price of $6.99
per month whilst this is North American
based initially the platform will of
course be spreading worldwide though
exact details are unknown at this point
on day one the platform will possess 18
Pixar films all Star Wars movies the
mandalorian Bounty Hunter TV show 250
hours of National Geographic 13 classic
Disney movies and almost all of the MCU
films and 30 seasons of The Simpsons
there's also going to be a lady in the
trampled live-action TV show as well as
a new what if Marvel series the first of
these whilst not dropping on launch day
will center around Peggy Carter and will
present an alternative version of events
in which she took the Super Soldier
Serum instead of Steve Rogers as also
set to be a Star Wars prequel show
centering around k2x oh and Cassie and
handle from rogue one and this will
flesh out their fight as rebels High
School Musical we'll also be getting a
10 episode series to accompany the
launch the Mandalorian written by Jon
Favreau is set after the fall of the
Empire and before the emergence of the
first order and follows a lone
gunfighter attempting to bring order to
his life amongst the chaos down the line
there are also some quite big plans in
terms of marble releases there's going
to be a Falcon and Winter Soldier show
as well as one centered around Loki and
they're set to head to the platform
within year 1 and year 2 respectively
wonder slash division is also set to
follow these and will feature elizabeth
Olsen and Paul Bettany reprising their
roles
the characters the day one Disney
Classics will be made up of 101
Dalmatians Aladdin Bambi PE and the
Beast Snow White and more there's so
much content and I can't believe they're
dropping all this day one this is
obviously a steal for less than seven
dollars a month and Netflix are probably
shaking in their boots right now
this is great news for Disney fans and
personally I can't wait to binge watch
the Marvel movies and TV shows on the
platform I just hope it comes to the UK
before the end of the year anyway that's
everything you need to know about the
new Disney Plus service obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on it as well
as what you're most excited for make
sure you comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and if you missed
yesterday's breakdown of Netflix's black
summer and don't worry because that'll
be linked at the end of this one this is
the channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
you
[Music]
[Music]